welcome to to London you you've been
here for a while
couple days and I thought about you
because you are you are born and bred in
New Jersey and you have your house there
is a waterfront house and I wonder how
how are things I mean it's bad did you
speak to your family yeah my family are
safe they've been moved to a hotel so
they're safe there they're in a place
it's got food and power but um all of
our houses have there there's no power
there's no water the devastation is off
the charts bad the president is in my
hometown now in New Jersey it's it's
like Armageddon it's like it's like
nothing we've ever seen it's it's 9/11
and Katrina rolled into one
and so I'm heading home first thing in
the morning as soon as I can land the
airports have been under water
it's been bad um this is this is not
only your home it's it's where you come
from it's it's your my people this is my
people yeah it's it's my neighbors it's
the neighborhood said I know it's where
my children surf 80 houses burned down
where you know where my key word player
has his beach house the houses are on
fire my hometown the president would not
go to my hometown it sounded you know
it's it's not a big place and it's not
even on the ocean and he's there because
of the devastation it's it's bad what
can he do I gotta get there and find out
you know well we take care of each other
people will gather round and and uh you
know that that's that's what happens in
these times people come together and
this this is not only not only your home
it's also your your your studio and it's
your office where you run
Bon Jovi company or what we call it tell
me what what what kind of boss are you a
boss more of a benevolent dictator is
welcome your opinions and then reject
them in time but you know I'm pretty
welcoming I I certainly share everything
with everybody and thoughts with
everybody and you know it really is a
team is it is it the your your
leadership style is it democratic or is
it everybody participates everybody is
an integral part of the team and then
but they know who they work for it what
about presents did they get presents
present great thanks I'd like to work
this is the way to make it bound work
over time I got thrown out of one I'm
not exactly in one again now I wouldn't
know very well
Robbie I'd love this guy's music for a
lot of years he's an incredibly talented
guys nothing to be fearful if he's one
of the great entertainers period in the
last 20 30 years
the video stuff that reunions would take
that we're all cool but his solo career
is outstanding that's got some major
talent thank you me back to you god
bless you one of the reasons I think you
are that Rob well you are such a great
showman is because you do doubt yourself
however that's the curse do you do you
know you don't I know this is a
brilliant place you see it's a gang and
that gang me we're in a band so you know
what that is
no we never lacked self-confidence when
you did you solo stuff or when you do
you solo stuff yeah is it different to
her is that do you question your ability
in any way or no it is based on success
or failure that's the artistic
expression and the only thing I asked
the Lord for is the opportunity to do it
again I don't care what happens with the
rest of me because I put my best effort
to get it to that place whatever happens
I one thing I'll never have been was a
coulda shoulda woulda kind of guy
anything I wanted to do fail or succeed
at it I did if it didn't work oh well
how much do you think that's got to do
with where you come from because it's a
very gritty go and do it kind of place
industrial Bruce Springsteen's from the
same neck of the woods how much is that
your people and the influence of them
because we weren't in a major metropolis
so we could we could we could hone our
craft in nightclubs and there was no
media to pay attention to us or it and
it was at a much different time I'm
talking about you know the late 70s so
when we were in in that place developing
our craft there was nothing and you were
close enough to New York City to see the
light and to feel that but far enough
away that you could fall and and figure
it out and we weren't in LA you know so
we were in the little suburban place
called New Jersey I'm sorry I don't I
don't think that sort of doubt is much
of an American good time here Erica
this dance very often but you know
there's not there's not like doubt it's
not an American thing really I think
that the the thing that I've got which
is a load of doubt it might be a British
thing I don't know that right do you
have teenagers yeah my daughter is just
shy of 20 she's our eldest and then my
eldest son is 18 and then another son
who's 10 and another son who's 8 how is
it for a teenager to have Jon Bon Jovi's
as a father
they're not there they don't run around
listening to my records no I had it
begged my daughter to listen to the new
record you know it's like what do you
think cuz they're onto a whole different
style of music now you know but um they
don't dislike it and they're very aware
of who their dad is obviously but it's
it's just not a big deal in our house
it's not a big and you actually you
really on tour you're coming back to
Europe on tour it's called because we
can is that is that why you're doing
takes just hits zero obviously there you
go it's the American thing why because
we can it's the name of the first single
really just it was that kind of thing
where